There lived a girl named Sara in India.
Her father decided to send her to London.
Why do I have to live in London?
Because India is too hot for you, Sara.
Sara's father had a lot of money but had no other relatives.
So he sent her to Miss Minchin's school for girls.
Miss Minchin was an old, mean looking woman.
"Oh! You will be the best student,"...
...said Miss Minchin.
For the first year, Sara was the best student.
She was smart and very clever.
But after the year, a letter came bringing very bad news.
Sara's father had died, leaving Sara with no one to take care of her!.
"Oh, no!"...
...exclaimed Sara.
What shall I do?
"You owe a lot of money to our school,"...
...said Miss Minchin.
Stay here and work hard until you pay your debt.
You will have to sleep in the attic, however.
Sara started to live in the attic with Becky.
Becky was a very kind and good-natured girl who worked at the school.
Sara's life became very hard.
Every day, she had to run errands and every night, she had to study.
"I wish I were a princess,"...
...said Sara.
Don't be sad, Sara. It's not as miserable as you think.
They say that after a heavy rain, the skies are clear.
Becky comforted Sara.